this morning on the dish eric kim in his
new cookbook korean american the new
york times food columnist writes getting
a recipe out of my mother is like
pulling teeth out of a tiger's mouth but
two years ago kim did just that moving
back home to atlanta to translate his
mother's intuitive recipes into dishes
the rest of us can share with our
families i met up with kim at the new
york times cooking studio for the
ultimate home cooked meal
as a cooking writer for the new york
times food section eric kim's job is to
develop recipes delicious and accessible
for all kinds of cooks
do you cook much at home
not as much as i should
[Laughter]
kim does it with dishes like sheet pan
bibimbap pb means mixed pop means rice
usually i do kale but i saw some really
great broccolini that was like kind of
flowering it's really pretty so i
figured we would do some broccoli action
his version includes assorted vegetables
that are chopped and oven roasted this
is the millennial version it's the money
version i would say let's go a unique
spin on the typically pan-fried korean
staple it's a recipe he developed two
years ago when at 28 kim left new york
and moved to atlanta to live with his
parents while working on his cookbook
i was
coming in and telling my mom
that i'm going to do things a little
differently these are these very like
classic dishes you know and
an idea like this she can pee pop she
should kind of be like i don't know like
koreans don't do that but i was like i
know but we're korean american
so we can do what we want we can do what
we want
kim is used to writing clear and
detailed instructions to make a meal and
wanted to specify what he calls his
mother's son mot
or her unique taste
for me my mom's food is immeasurable
but as a recipe writer
i had to approximate it at least get
people like a little close
with the measurements after spending
nearly a year in the kitchen with his
mom jean the results of their culinary
journey can be found in kim's first
cookbook korean american food that
tastes like home how joyful is it to
like to have a bite of food and be like
whoa never had that taste before right
let's make it which
here we go let's go
i'm gonna take these out first
good job on those look at that
yes
eat as you go
the potatoes onions broccolini and
mushrooms are placed in quadrants over
the rice
topped with a fried egg
drizzled with sesame oil it's art it's a
nice presentation a dessert this is what
is going to flavor
the whole bowl the final step a choice
of gochujang a fermented chili paste or
duenjong a soybean paste the final thing
there's no final thing that's it that's
it
then you just have to eat it you just
mix it up
you go from this beautiful thing of
everything separated too
yeah destroy it's really just it's for
you it's like yeah
i love that it's fun right fun to eat
deviled eggs so for kim korean-american
is more than a cookbook it's a journey
of discovery of the korean cuisine he
grew up eating and of identity
kim's parents immigrated to the u.s in
the 1980s growing up in atlanta he began
watching the food network as a teenager
eventually turning an interest into a
career
for our dish kim prepared sesame soy
deviled eggs with black sesame seeds
a gem salad
and creamy bucatini pasta yes mom cream
he crumbles keem a roasted seaweed over
each one let's toss this
it's been uh
it's an all-purpose uh
seasoner i definitely use it i
definitely use it that way and i think
some people would be like okay enough
with the keem but um for me it's like
the flavor of my childhood i really just
you know everyone has the thing that
really takes them back yeah they're
christine madeline for me it's the taste
of sesame oil salt and seaweed it's just
like the perfect trifecta flavors
an entire chapter in the cookbook is
devoted to kimchi i love these moments
like in the book
an example of korean cuisine in which
kim says time is the main ingredient
this is what my mom does she flips her
chopstick like this
and that means it's usually to like mix
noodles for the table but i'm gonna do
it to give you one of these okay but
then there's also this this is napa
cabbage okay okay so this is the one
we're probably like this is the one that
i knew always a lot of people are
familiar with them but there are
different kinds and they all have
different sweetnesses like different
flavors and
i mean i'm gonna have some of this too
what does your mom think of this
everyone kept asking me that i kept
forgetting to ask her
i got her on stage with me and of course
she's really proud she's always you know
been
someone who's like proud of her children
i've also seen her light up a little bit
you know this this book really puts her
front and center and i'm also really
glad to highlight her talent she's a
culinary artist like she's a really good
i think that's something that now people
get to taste kim believes that true
talent in the kitchen means having
something to say with your food and he
says food has helped him express his
true self what is korean american to you
i actually had friends who who were like
maybe you should call something more
that sounds more personal um but for me
nothing could be more personal than
these words and i think it's because
this book is
about my journey towards
accepting
who i am just like as
as i am because when i started writing
this book i was terrified of what other
koreans would think really because i
think so often
people see
food or recipe on the page and they'll
be like my mom doesn't do it like that
these flavors they always hearken back
to a memory i have a taste a real thing
it's not fusion food this is my life
i love that oh this is my life so i did
bring you a drink
sorry i didn't make you the bibimbap
again but that was delicious
the clementine 5050 soju vermouth and
clementine juice so cheers and the
cookbook's amazing sure i'm going to do
the bibimbap with jack
easy to make easy to make
i am starving after that's good i'm
starving after watching that pizza i
know really good and it's really this
nice mix he doesn't call it fusion
because it's not fusion it's just how he
grew up eating and the way he changed
some food